[Music]
hi everyone can you guys hear me yeah
awesome
welcome to the top rml the assembly line
of machine learning and just like Dan
said my name is Maya Powell I work in
the Salesforce Einstein team and I
manage our automated machine learning
product initiative and today we I'm
going to talk about our homegrown
machine learning library called Optimus
Prime which helps automate machinery -
all right so let's get started so a
little small thing you guys all know
that Salesforce is a publicly traded
company so we have a great active legal
team so this is a forward-looking
statement I was about to explain every
single word here but I'll save you the
trouble
long story short don't buy CS for stocks
just based upon the session all right a
mix so
I want to talk a lot about corruption as
primaries and how we are automating
machine learning but I think it's great
to set the context and explain why we
invested in Optimus Prime in the first
place so you guys were mostly the
keynote and I think there was a point
made about in the real world building a
machine learning is not just about the
modeling algorithm there's a lot of
center stage you know machine learning
algorithms takes a lot of sentient State
but there's a lot of work which goes on
into the pipeline which means ETL
teacher engineering and once you have
done your feature engineering you would
actually get into the stage of training
your model and once you train your model
generally all of you have worked in a
data scientist and machine learning you
would see that the model generally
doesn't perform very well so that's the
evaluation stage and you have to iterate
and train the model many many times
through different parameters and often
times you have to go back to all the way
to your feature engineering process and
then once you do that you have to go
ahead and figure out how do you deploy
and operationalize your model and once
you do that you have to think about
scoring and you have to think about
versioning of your models so little show
of hands how many of you guys have been
involved in actually deploying a model
into production awesome and how many of
you are actually involved in modeling
hundreds of models in production today
that's cool
awesome so why I asked that at
Salesforce we have to do it many many
many times over and let me explain why
there are two factors involved
Salesforce is an enterprise company so
we built business solutions for many
different verticals
for instance financial companies sales
marketing e-commerce IOT an example is
US bank is one of her retail customers
so they're a financial company and they
have like sixteen point nine million
retail clients and what they want to
find out is which of those retail
clients would resonate well with their
wealth management value proposition so
that their financial advisers can
actually prioritize those retail clients
and sell them the wealth management
solution in other use cases of their
existing wealth management customers
which of those are about to churn or at
write because they want to retain them
going forward and incentivize them
accordingly so US Bank is just one
customer since we are a business to
business company we have hundreds of
such customers
and each of those customers data set
looks completely different it has a
different shape and different form so
the model that we built for one customer
does not work for another
the second wrinkle here is I talked
about two use cases but across all of
these different verticals we have many
other use cases and then we have a long
tail of use cases there are some really
funny ones that I've heard that how long
does it take for your visa to get
approved we have certain nonprofits
which we work with with a college
student drop out of the college then
there are some in the logistics
department they say like would this
truck break down in the next 30 days and
can we predict that ahead of time so
that we can solve that problem so it's a
combination of the number of customers
we also call it tenant so it's
multi-channel machine learning and the
number of use cases across these
verticals which makes it an order of
magnitude harder problem for us it's
like a scale of different sorts the
second important thing all of you're
probably aware of this that machine
learning software is different from
traditional software and there are many
different ways to actually state that
fact and there are a lot of literature
around it so this is just one
perspective which is any software is
actually at the end of the day or
troubleshooting a debugging problem we
all know that when we built a software
it doesn't work straight out of the box
so you have to go back and tweak it so
in a traditional software if you see the
X and the y-axis there are two
dimensions what algorithm you're
implementing is algorithm correct to
begin with and second have you
implemented it correctly once we get
into the machine learning software
domain it turns out there are two
additional dimension which gets added so
the z axis is model issues is there
model overfitting and the fourth
dimension is data related issues do you
have enough data do you have leakage
going on in your data do you have like
data which is very messy and not clean
and we all know that those of you who
have done it that most of the data does
look like that so suddenly from a two
dimensional problem it becomes a 4
dimensional debugging problem and hence
a bit more complicated next we know
there's a lot of different machine
learning frameworks I think the
gentleman in the keynote also talked
about this and some call his framework
some would call it library some would
call it platform and each of them has
serves or so
Anish use case a specific application so
if you're starting out or even with
someone with reasonable experience and
tribal knowledge is sometimes very hard
to figure out where you really start
what do you really use and all of these
factors combined it turns out there are
not enough data scientists in the whole
world
to do all the kind of modeling that you
want to do here at Salesforce and we
want to really do it to actually make it
truly accessible to our business
customers who makes it accessible to
their end users - at the end of the day
the consumers so how do we really
Democrat arise machine learning if you
don't have enough data scientists and
that's the motivation that helped us
actually that necessitate the birth of
Optimus Prime at Salesforce I'm gonna
talk a lot about that but the key
message the key value proposition here
is can you build a model which achieves
90% or more accuracy than a handcraft in
an enhancing model but here's the kicker
not with one full two fold but 100x
reduction and time and effort so that's
what we are focusing on and an analogy
that I like to give is about Auto
Mobile's and you know when cars first
came into the market they were super
expensive and you know it took a lot of
time to build and manufacture each and
every one of them and hence it was
inaccessible to the majority of the
population but then Henry Ford came into
the picture he put cars on the assembly
line and quickly they got way cheaper
they got you know the time needed to
manufacture one short and dramatically
it got way more accessible so we're
trying to do the same thing for machine
learning as Henry Ford did for cars so
I'm gonna do a little fun inside there's
a code someone said that in software
there are two very hard things so one is
cash and validation and another is
naming of a software so we were
struggling with a lot to find out what
would be the right name for this
software so this is a library built on
top of spark and spark ml and uses color
as a functional programming language and
it's really a collection of transformers
which you can stack one after another to
build your assembly line and so aptly we
named it Optimus Prime after the
character from the movie transformers
but soon we realized that there are some
trademark issues duly brought by our
amazing marketing and legal team that we
cannot use this name but we were using
the abbreviation OB everywhere
the court and no one really wanted to
change it so we were trying to find a
name which fits that Opie has an
abbreviation yet it captures the soul of
transformers so what we did is we
removed four letters in the world
Optimus and replaced it with something
called octopus fried and well we don't
know if the name would stick so if you
guys have better suggestions come to me
after the talk I would love to hear from
you guys but it's a bit ironic right
it's a library of transformers and it
turns out that Optimus Prime transformed
himself to something called octopus
prime which he says like a multi-legged
data transformer all right
so octopus prime is our automated
machine learning library it had helped
accelerate data scientist productivity
as sales force by almost tomorrow you
don't necessarily need to have a PhD or
an advanced machine learning degree to
leverage machine learning and you can
build predictive applications in hours
not months or releases which it was
taking us before and many of our
customers actually put the data within
Salesforce so we have schema and
metadata around the data so we try to
leverage that that's what I meant by it
natively supports Salesforce objects
because if you know some of those schema
and those relationships you can leverage
that in your machine learning feature
engineering and a model selection
process and lastly as we are not writing
new algorithms so we're not reinventing
the wheel here so we're at the spark ml
algorithm so if there is a newer and
better little garden which is
contributed by the community we would
automatically wrap it so you can
leverage the ongoing improvements so I
want to pause here and mention one thing
because this comes up from time to time
like the model that we are trying to
build it does not replace if you're a
data scientist we have tribal knowledge
who have experienced and applied machine
learning if you come up with a handcraft
and an hand-tuned model this is no match
for that however the point that I'm
trying to make is how many of us really
need a roaster eyes to go from point A
to B when a Toyota or Honda can really
do the job so in the next section of the
talk you know having said the motivation
and what this is all about we're going
to go under the hood and I would really
try to explain like what kind of
automation
we are doing so there are three aspects
to it so there's automated feature
engineering there is automated feature
selection and then there is automated
model selection so we'll talk about each
of them a bit so here's an example of
automated feature engineering so these
are some of the features we have so in
this library you also have a rich
hierarchy type hierarchy so you can
define a feature as email which is very
common feature as a form age is a text
feature sub sorry age is a numeric
feature subject is a text feature and
zip code is a special kind of feature
and so depending on this type this is
again just a snapshot we would figure
out if this email is spammy or not and
that's a new kind of a feature we
derived or transformed from the original
feature another very common thing that
we do we would extract the domain of the
email and we do on one heart encoding so
you can imagine if someone has a gmail
address versus a hotmail address versus
a yahoo address it might mean different
thing also in our context sometimes you
also have to figure if it's a business
address or it circles you are a personal
address because that might mean
something different form we would
extract the country code the area code
which actually has a lot of signal about
what the location is and then we would
also figure out the phone is valid or
not
so imagine someone going to a like a
company website and signing up for for
some white paper and putting in their
phone number the likelihood of that
person converting to a real user would
be high if they really put their valid
phone number versus they put in
something spammy
age is a numeric feature we would
automatically bucket eyes numeric
features into buckets like in most of
the libraries you have to manually
select the buckets you have to say from
this to this but how do you really come
to know like what those buckets would be
so we use decision tree behind the
scenes to actually figure out what those
buckets would be based upon the
information game subject is a text
feature we would do top tf-idf turns we
also do hashing tokenization and some of
the other stuff so the same zip code is
a special kind of feature because it
gives us an opportunity to also augment
so we can use other external datasets so
based upon zip code we can bring in for
instance average income and actually
make your features richer than it was to
begin with and all of this we would then
vectorize and create those pretty
numeric 0 1 matrix which most of your
machine algorithms are actually desire
or require because
you cannot feed any of these features in
the format in which it is and as I said
this is the tip of the iceberg so this
is kind of more expanded comprehensive
scope that we have done based upon the
type of feature it is for example
numerically we would do automatically
null indicators because if a lot of
features are now it might have a lot of
might have very interesting signal
imputation strategies smart binning
which I just talked about scaling and
log normalization for categorical
feature we would do all of those and
then we would do one hot encoding we
would also do dynamic TopGear pivot what
what is that like I was just giving an
example of email addresses but imagine
state right there are like 50 states in
the US but if your data is mostly as a
top 10 states maybe you can do top 10 of
those and the rest are others so that
your feature engineering space that
doesn't get exploded on the tech side
tokenization hash encoding tf-idf or
Tyvek we also embed sentiment analysis
and language detection because many of
these text features are really dependent
on what language you're using time-based
features time difference is important
many time feature also captures
seasonality because if there is analogy
in your business we would do circular
statistics to capture it time extraction
that is day of the week week of the
month month of the month of the year and
so on and closeness to major events or
if there's a Christmas Thanksgiving or
some event happening it might be a very
important signal for spatial features we
would do geo encoding the example that I
talked talked about augmenting with
external data and some of the other
stuff we are working on in our roadmap
so and another thing that I want to
mention like like each of these like
even if you think about imputation there
are tons of research papers how you can
do imputation like you can do you can
just say fill it up with a mean or you
can fill it up with zero or now or you
can actually do some crazy regressions
just to figure out how you would improve
it so like for for someone what we have
seen earlier what was happening is like
they're different teams different data
scientists teams and machine learning
teams each of them were coming up with
their own different implementation of
implication and at times we saw though
the implementation was very different
the goal was the same so there was a lot
of reputation a lot of redundance and so
we put all of this research into
place and because this is some of the
repetitive work so we were trying to
automate these things so you can just
call this and immediately get value out
of it okay so that was automatic feature
engineering the next is automatic
feature selection so what do I mean by
that so each of these features that we
fed in we would actually compute
descriptive statistics around it such as
min mean max number of nulls variance
standard deviations why because many of
these features you know might not have
acceptable ranges that's what the
real-world data looks like for instance
if you have an age feature and you have
negative values there's something wrong
with that feature to begin with so we
need to detect those things
automatically next we would do
associations of these features with the
label so these are examples of
correlation r is a correlation measure
if r is high it's good because this is a
feature with a good signal if R is zero
this means this feature does not really
have any predictive signal it's garbage
so based upon that we would drop
features which are not very helpful and
so limit the feature space which can
actually help in how fast you can either
it on the modeling part this is the
second part of automatic feature
selection and this we have seen a lot in
enterprise data space which we call data
leakage or label leakage this happens
when information from the label creeps
into your current feature and this is a
real-world use case I was talking about
the lead score lead score is the
predicting what is the likelihood of a
lead converting to a sale and these are
the top predicted factors and what we
saw was there was this feature called
lead value which was there in the data
set and it was getting filled up with an
estimate the moment the lead is about to
get converted to a sale so you can
imagine that if you use a machine
learning algorithm with this feature to
Train it would perform great in your
research environment it will probably
get very point 99 accuracy but in the
real world that feature won't really be
available and your model would perform
very poorly and this is just an example
because our date our business has used
different kind of ETL processes
different workflow processes different
methods of entry data and there is a
huge problem in the data entry and so
because of this unknown business
processes like I mean this is a huge
bottleneck because if you cannot solve
this we can't really get to the next
stage of creating realistic models
and finally the automated model
selection I think most of the in the
industry when they talk about automated
machine learning they really just focus
on automated model selection and not
some of the steps and the stages that I
talked about before and automated model
selection has again two parts its
automated hyper parameter tuning so this
is the space of hyper parameters and
we're trying to find the best type of
parameter and I stole this jiff
animation from the guys at Zagat which I
really liked like how can you take a
complex algorithm and actually visualize
it so there are three different
approaches if you see the spaces where
we are trying to find the hybrid
parameters the yellow dots are actually
the hyper parameters in a grid search is
kind of dumb it just goes line by line
trying to figure out oh is this the best
hyper parameter but it can work pretty
well depending how small your data set
is and how good your use cases sometimes
dumb methods really work well and then
we have random search which gets
slightly smarter and then we have
Bayesian search which is a much more
intelligent approach might work great
with great bigger data sets because a
grid search might just never complete
with a big complicated data sets and
there are other advanced methods
intelligent approaches that you can use
for your hyper parameter tuning like you
can use a genetic algorithm or particle
based approach we haven't done all this
thing but this is still kind of future
work kind of in a roadmap so depending
upon the class of machine learning
problem that you are trying to solve
whether it's a regression problem binary
classification problem or multi-class
classification problem we would use
together with those hyper parameters we
would compete different models for
instance in regression we will use
gradient boosted trees decision trees
random forests GL ours and see which
model performs the best for this data
set this is important because the same
model might not perform the best in all
kinds of data so that I talked about in
the beginning and this is one of my
favorite slides actually in this
presentation right if you're wondering
like okay you're doing automated feature
engineering model selection feature
selection but what is the point like
what are we really trying to get out of
it and the point is like you can use a
combination of all of these tactics and
each of the
I'm saying it's a method and you can see
that the the difference between method 1
and Method 13 even if I eyeball is like
500-person
increase in your evaluation metric
whichever you choose in this case it's
just an example we are using a URL see
and traditionally a data scientist would
actually do all of this
like manually they would try different
feature engineering there were try
different models and they would see the
results and go back and we're and it
takes a lot of time it's very
time-consuming and we're trying to see
how we can get to that much faster so
that we can actually build as predictive
applications much faster so basically a
diverse set of features and models can
lead to very different results
okay so this is my Disneyland slide and
which is like once we use all of this
models all of those methods we have been
able to reduce the time that has taken
us to build predictive application from
months to hours and we are doing so this
is actually powering our underlying
platform which actually helps our
customers build predictive applications
today we are doing more than a billion
predictions per day on this platform and
this is another very interesting slide
it's a time period of a year how many
models were deployed to production
completely hands-free there used to be a
y-axis it was removed because of PR
comments so you're not sure it would
have loved to show it okay so let's
recap so I talked about that machine
learning is slightly complex it needs a
lot of PhDs there's an overwhelming
number of technologies it's
time-consuming it's really hard to scale
like building one models to production
is hard enough like when you have to
build thousands of such models of
production it's really doesn't scale up
to octopus prime was born out of
necessity at sales first it are its
automated machine learning library and
the key value proposition is here again
this can be achieved 90% or more
accuracy again I'm using accuracy as a
like a superset of all evaluation metric
it can be something else with hundred X
reduction in time and an effort and
today o P is our sales force internal
platform and it's powering hundreds of
enterprise customers truly
democratization learning to our business
customers and to their end users and
with that excite thank you
questions comments yes
was going back
dimensions exploding quantities of data
both features number of models amount of
like rows of data yes presumably using
spark to parallelize all that out but on
watch dimensions are you paralyzing so
each of those models would be paralyzed
so what we are running and we also
paralyze sometimes the feature
engineering processor
so you mentioned something about data
leakage and not getting do you have any
ways of automatically figuring out if
your data is correct in some sense or
not
yeah the current codings of wrong or
different definitions of variables
across time stuff like that can you
repeat the last part of different
definitions if a variable change the
definition across time who do you have
any other way
so this is a really good question and
thank you for that and so initially I
showed some examples that we were doing
some kind of a correlations with the
label but correlations works great if
your data is filled up many other times
and it's not very sparse and
correlations also works for numeric
features who are monotonically
increasing or they're the Association is
related to that of the label it doesn't
work very well for categorical features
for instance if you have a categorical
feature with only three values it would
work but if you have 10 or 20 values
then it doesn't work because the other
feature values would dilute the total
correlation that you are having with
that label so that's why we started
investing in chemistry we started seeing
what lots of other problems like text
feature in Salesforce and notorious
everyone dumps everything into text so
not all of these are really text
features so we are we have to do
cardinality analysis on some of those
text features to figure out are they
really text or they're numeric or
categorical so we can apply different
feature engineering process one of the
bigger problems which you are kind of
hinting it as the data that we are often
training on is shifting it's drifting
and the actual data that we are scoring
on looks very different so we're doing a
distribution analysis between our
training and the scoring data like we're
looking at the fill rates of each of
these features like how did the
distribution look like to figure out
that if it's the like the the
fundamental assumption of machine
learning is the data that you're
training on is similar to the data that
you're scoring so through those
distribution analysis we try to figure
out that if if there is a problem and so
you know flag it maybe we have to
retrain it maybe you have to drop
certain things we have seen other very
interesting issues like there's a
certain feature which is very very
important which was used
suddenly stops getting used and there's
a new feature which was never used
before starts getting used and you talk
to the customer they say nobody is still
using this feature but then we look at
the data no you're not really using that
feature so
one of the joke here at Salesforce is as
we're trying to build as machine
learning applications what we have seen
is it has made our customers look more
closely into the data which they have
never really looked into before so it's
not a solved problem it's a really hard
problem especially when it comes to the
difference between the leakers and the
true predictors like it's about the
thresholds and we're still working on it
there's a lot of research going on into
it
hi I'm a pretty habit we user of
Salesforce awesome thank you just a
quick question on the output of that so
when you define elite to be more likely
to become a sale what is the time range
there and how do you use the output of
your prediction and trend it over time
if it doesn't become a sale for example
yeah that's it I guess yeah so if I if I
if I understood the question correctly
like it's very easy to say that a lead
has converted a positive label but how
do you really figure out it's a negative
label like when do you really do that
and I think it really depends on some of
these use cases like we actually look at
the distribution like the leads and how
long does it take how long does it stay
and then based upon that you can
actually figure out that what should be
the time line where in some cases it's
like 30 days like if they haven't
converted within 30 days then they're
probably more likely to be negative
example in some data sets it's not 30
days that's 50 days so again it's the
same thing like we cannot use just one
threshold and do it I think there is
another talk I think later today like
the folks from open doors coming and
I've heard the similar talk before I
think they're talking about like how do
you really predict your house is gonna
really be sold and like how long is it
the market and they were they would
probably talk about like you know when
it's sold you really know but it's not
sold you don't know what's really
happening and they talked about
different strategies to do that for them
it's slightly easier because you're just
looking at houses and houses and sales
for us like it's leads it's just an
example for a different use case it
might take a year to actually the
attrition use case for instance I was
talking about our churn or college
drop-off sometimes you have to wait for
a year worth of data to really figure
out that if this is really a negative
signal or not so it's hard hi so
training different types of models can
obviously take a long time but then
adding in parameters can add exponential
amount of time so have you guys looked
at I guess which parameters for certain
models are coming up
currently and like change the way you
guys choose the parameters like have you
been smart about like yeah which
parameters you've chosen we haven't but
there is a thought process on a similar
line so let's say if you use certain
hyper parameters and your training
algorithm and you can learn from the
previous one actually store it somewhere
so it can you can retrieve it and don't
start from the scratch again so that's
where you can paralyze actually
computationally it's much easier from
that perspective but spark really helps
so to paralyze and if you really
paralyze things in the proper way I
think that helps a lot one more thing
that I wanted to mention which is
related to this so this is all the
training part which is kind of happening
right now in the batch mode so it kind
of takes time but once you actually
figure out the model the scoring part is
much more faster so in the training time
it does take some time but it's like
well the alternate is much more worse
right you know it would take months so
do you ever find there are tensions
between the sort of desires of the
different machine learning algorithms
and the Transformers and their output so
if you're for example one Hutt encoding
your categoricals and decision trees
would really like to have every option
available to split on but a regression
would prefer that you drop one and let
the intercept capture that there's it
seems like there might be a tension
there in terms of what those models want
yeah yeah so actually this happens so I
talked about the auto bucket izing thing
that I was talking about like in numerix
would figure out buckets we're actually
using it's kind of like an ensemble
models we're using a decision tree to
actually figure out those buckets which
is great when you're using something
like a logistic regression and stuff so
whenever data science it doesn't really
help when you're using a decision tree
because that's what a decision tree or a
random forest do in the to begin with so
like we would use that with the decision
tree or not use that with sorry we will
use them with a logistic regression and
with a decision tree we won't auto
bucket eyes and we'll try those
different approaches because sometimes
run a random forest a decision tree does
not always work best like I know that
random forests are generally winner in
most of the cases but not always
[Music]